nos mataron desde adentro es el título
de un informe condenatorio elaborado por
human rights watch tras una
investigación sobre la mortífera
explosión del puerto de beirut de agosto
de 2020 la explosión fue causada por
toneladas de nitrato de amonio que
llegaron en el buque rochus en 2013 el
informe implica a varios altos
dirigentes libaneses y concluye que
fueron criminalmente negligentes en el
manejo del cargamento creando un riesgo
no razonable para la vida los detalles
del informe exponen décadas de mala
gestión y de corrupción por parte del
gobierno por soul censura en dar
funcionarios incluidos unos de máximo
nivel en el gobierno y en los servicios
de seguridad han estado desviando
responsabilidades desde que ocurrió la
explosión hace un año lo que nuestro
informe demostró es que todas estas
personas que nombramos no sólo sabían
del nitrato de amonio sino que sabían de
los peligros que esto plantea otras
fosas baide tenían la responsabilidad de
actuar y no lo hicieran tan falta el
informe también pide a las naciones
unidas que ordene una investigación
internacional
siguen sin respuesta a las preguntas
sobre quién ordenó el envío de los
productos químicos y porque los
funcionarios ignoraron las repetidas
advertencias entretanto el juez del país
encargado del caso ha solicitado permiso
para procesar a los implicados
la explosión de beirut es una de las
mayores explosiones no nucleares de la
historia destruyó amplias zonas de la
capital y afectó a cientos de miles de
personas desde entonces el país ha
luchado por recuperarse en medio de una
grave crisis económica enfrentando la
escasez de alimentos básicos y de
medicinas